yes another 3d gimmick thrown into a
movie like they can't help it at this
point step up 3d
alright so me personally I love dancing
and dance choreography I mean this
shit's just badass son let's face it
that's what step-up 3ds really all about
everything else in this movie can get
shit-canned but the dancing is badass
alright so right off the bat there is a
bait and switch in this movie from the
trailer and the poster it looks like
that really hot girl with the really hot
ass is the main character in this movie
you know the character that's pretty
much the eyes of the audience like c-3po
but it's not that characters this
michael cera looking kid who has some
pretty sick dance moves which i
personally think is awesome cuz skinny
white guys like me we generally dance
like oh good to see someone breaking the
mold now as I mentioned this movie is
all about the dance moves but in this
movie this guy's filming this
documentary and at a point you realize
I'd rather just watch that I mean if I
watched a really cool documentary about
dancing I could skip the shitty plot and
the subpar acting to elements in this
movie that no matter how you slice it
they're bad to be honest the plot is
laughably predictable the moment I saw
the main douchebag I was like let me
guess you two used to be friends it's
not a spoiler trust me it's that obvious
and from there you know exactly how the
movies gonna play out as if you wrote it
yourself and the acting okay it almost
goes without say that when someone's in
a movie for the sake of their talent
like their fighting ability or their
dancing ability their acting is going to
be absolute [ __ ] but if you go and
do a movie like step up 3d for the
acting or the plot I'm gonna smack you
when I punch the screen at the end of
this video you're gonna get smacked just
saying but the actors are better than
the guy who ruined Vader so there is
that no the 3d actually wasn't horrible
alright I'll say it was actually pretty
good couple of moments where your eyes
start going cross they start doing weird
3d gimmick things like and the fingers
all popping out of the screen your eyes
just go yeah that hurts and there's the
scene where this dance crew has these
little LEDs on their shirt and the 3d
just didn't mix with that they're either
in their chests or way out to here on
them yeah that was bad 3d that was
[ __ ] but it is the best live-action
3d movie we've seen since avatar really
not saying much but just saying so even
though the dancing was just the most
badass dancing I've seen on the big
screen it's really hard for me to
justify telling you to go pay an
overpriced ticket at 3d prices to see
some really impressive dancing when
there's really impressive dancing right
here on the Internet you're on YouTube
you could watch it like right now I'd
say if hip-hop dance is your thing
acting's not gonna bother you at all and
either as a plot that's really not why
you go and see this movie you see it for
the dancing and the dancing is badass
and nobody can deny that so I said go
say it but if you're one of those I need
a solid movie with solid acting and a
solid script and I'll YouTube the dance
segments later kind of people and skip
it so [ __ ] plot [ __ ] script [ __ ] acting
great dancing if you need more than one
out of four to enjoy a movie mmm luckily
you're on YouTube now so if you're a
luck go for it I also put a link below
of a really cool dance segment I saw
like a few years ago check that [ __ ] out
it's just cool but if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]